we now know why president biden has not
been to the border he's way too busy
do you have plans to visit the southern
border i've been there before and i
haven't i mean i know it well
i guess i should go down but the
but the whole point of it is i haven't
had a whole hell of a lot of time to get
down i've been spending time going
around looking at the 900 billion
dollars worth of damage done by
uh by hurricanes and floods and and
weather and traveling around the world
but
i plan on now my wife jill has been down
oh good
the white house got testy after being
pressed on biden's claim that he has
visited in the past without any evidence
well peter
as you may have seen there's been a
reporting that he
did drive through the border when he was
on the campaign trail in 2008 and he is
certainly familiar with the fact and it
stuck with him with the fact that uh in
el paso uh the border goes right through
the center of town does that count as a
visit he said i've been there before
you're saying he drove by for a few
minutes does that count
what do you what is the root cause where
are people coming from who are coming to
the border peter
greg she blamed trump but he drove
through the border 50 years in uh
politics and he drove through i uh i
also that if that counts i also actually
went to turkey once because i had a
connection there
like you know
do you ever do that you count where
you've been as a kid
yeah exactly god
actually no i just went to the gift shop
and waiting for my next flight i you
know
part of me says the less he does the
better but he's still doing stuff that's
the problem if he was just a bumbling
consultant hired because he's your
uncle's best friend that would be fine
but he's actually in charge of stuff and
it's kind of scary so i'm almost being
hypocritical saying that i should be
happy that the country's on autopilot
but maybe it's not on autopilot maybe
there's somebody in the cockpit and it's
driving this plane into the ground and
maybe they actually know what they're
doing
no it's somebody back in the galley
nipping at the sauce and there's nobody
in the cockpit potentially there you go
right jess um
why would he go to the border at this
point because he's going to be greeted
by the people who are trying to enforce
the enforce the laws of the country the
border patrol vilified falsely by biden
border patrol and horseback all the
ranchers who were now packing heat
wherever they go because people are like
swarming over their land they would be
he would get chance of let's go brandon
for sure
sorry
it's a good friday laugh there kennedy
going to the border and making
immigration
specifically from the southern border is
not something that democrats tend to do
that's just a fact it's nothing that
they want to run on this has been
consistent for decades uh donald trump
loved going to the border he's even gone
to the border since he hasn't been
president and he doesn't go to places
that he doesn't want to go he doesn't
want to show up in flint michigan and
talk to people about the water quality
there these are about electoral
priorities he does have someone is in
charge of the border to chicago when
they were in chicago he should have gone
down and seen the south side but he just
does events just like he said he's
el paso in 2008 drove to new mexico to
do a political event and then drove back
to the airport and flew out of there but
those are that's
your priority
and you think that that's what the most
important issue is
it's not the country's number one number
two issue facing this country illegal
immigration and you're upholstering you
should know that
well are you a poster yes she is i had
no idea big time pollster over here
don't she's pregnant
not great that's enough big time that
was bad i dare you that was bad greg
where's good greg
do you have anything else to say i just
was gonna say it's funny that he says
he's too busy to go to the border he
goes to delaware every weekend he's been
to camp david ten times taken ten times
he's been to an international trip once
this week he had a three day week he
took off friday and he took off monday i
don't know what he's doing golf outings
he doesn't do anything at least trump
went somewhere air force one sitting on
the tarmac
as well
air force one's it's just i feel bad for
air force one
come sit on me joe that's all air first
one says they just want us do something
all he does is go to scranton scranton
and michigan
[Laughter]
oh god hi he should go to the border uh
what what is happening to human beings
at our southern border is awful and
cruel and he's the president he signed a
bunch of immigration executive orders
that he is completely backtracked on uh
he is relying on the trump immigration
policy to the point of almost leg
humping i mean i just say that because
my dog has started doing that he
overturned he one of his executive
orders was strictly to just get back at
trump that's all it was yeah political
you emotional no way he's like you know
what the remaining mexico policy is
actually quite cogent let's go ahead and
use that uh they don't have a policy
they don't have a plan they should have
a plan they've got the votes they can do
something on immigration if they're not
going to get infrastructure if they're
not going to get this massive spending
bill passed then at least streamline the
system so people can humanely enter this
country so they're not passing through
uh viciously awful parts of central
america
to almost certain death in many cases
with kids unaccompanied being sexually
abused and
it's it's awful and they need to
acknowledge that and that's one of those
things another one of those things on
top of inflation the supply chain in
afghanistan where they pretend
everything is great it's not great it's
horrible i was just surprised that biden
wasn't prepared to answer that question
and did a crap job of answering it
despite anderson cooper
feeding him pureed food he also had the
question it was a pre-screen question dr
jill has been down there
i mean come on when your wife goes
somewhere it's basically the same thing
and by the way she's a medical doctor
she was probably there treating patients
yeah i have the same kind of doctor
and i'm a poster and i'm big
coming up what i meant
that's not what he meant
bolster not an offender like a
pejorative hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else